salut a tous j'espère que vous avez bien
moi ça va super très belle journée pour
pêcher aujourd'hui donc il ya du soleil
le seul problème c'est qu'un peu de
manque de nouvelles go pro ça devrait
aller à l'eau est aussi très froide je
lai un peu les mains je suis dans un
spot tous est déjà venu pas mal de fois
c'est l'endroit où on a trouvé tous les
morceaux de motos et de voitures
je sais qu'il reste des morceaux de la
kawasaki est la nuit sont dans le coin
cette vidéo a été tournée en deux fois
j'étais venu avec mon ancienne gopro
donc la qualité sera un peu moins bon au
début
le but ça va être récupéré leurs motos
par pièce et or ce qu'on peut trouver
d'autres
c'est parti pour la pêche est bien là
je crois que c'est une voie enfin en
tout cas les grosses au vin des monceaux
traitez-moi ste racines du bon bois ça
oa leur nickel
[Musique]
nice
ah non je me suis décalé et j'ai trouvé
une mine antipersonnel la déconne je
pars en ce que c'est
s'il y en a qui connaissent ce type de
mine dit le mans aux commentaires au
fond qu'est ce que c'est que ça encore
quand des partis d'une moto ça les gars
ça c'est un projet d'accord il est petit
cocon qui sont amusés ici par des
morceaux les gars
au maïs là des mois tous à dire qu'on a
beaucoup
tuba ça c'est sûr mais aussi un morceau
de la moto et je vais le garder
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres bon ça ok ça
c'est un marteau que casser ya le bois
dedans je sais pas ce que c'est
va pisser dessus mais c'est de la peau
et d'ailleurs
on parle d'un morceau tout à l'heure ça
c'est peut-être lié au parc c'est pas
bien chromé comme la moto
laurent et des péniches europe reste est
de lui
1 c'est chrome et encore
ne connais pas trop mais c'est possible
qu'une moto et ça j'en parle t'on une
moto exams le bon donc tu perds
serrières
rétroviseurs pas mal
il a bien morflé le petit pas
donc
sa mode des belles jantes
j'ai pas trop ce que c'est
selon les parties voiture ou moto
mon poignet du style années 70 sympa
quoi
à quelque chose je passe il a pas lâchés
n'ont peut-être pas
parce que c'est cette merde on aurait
dit un parapluie mais non ils scrutent
qui tourne là si vous pouvez me dire ce
que c'est dans les commentaires sur
preneur aura déjà
pas encore là
c'est bien beau de découper des voitures
des motos et coffre fort vous les mettez
où le gars je pèse depuis six mois je
crois et j'ai jamais fait un seul coffre
fort c'est fou j'ai fait presque tout ce
qu'un pêcheur peut avoir sans fin vous
offre encore un volant cerf-volant à
l'égard ça peut paraître atypique par
exemple un volant je me sépare de mon
premier à les trouver
j'étais un peu en meilleur état mais
voilà donc seconde partie vidéo
ouais etc dupliquer le péniche du quai
des péniches pour commencer oh là encore
regarder ça c'est sûrement encore des
morceaux de la moto
mais pour pas loin elle est sur toute
cette force et on a va changer quelque
chose
quelque chose de gros casques haut le
pot d'échappement oh la la
vous avez dit qu'il restait des grosses
parties et ça je crois que c'est partie
des disques de freins ou quelque chose
comme ça d'accord un beau pot
d'échappement bien éventrés à ces coupes
pour les vilains pas si mal et a
facilement mauvais état et il est plutôt
beau coup la caisse qui a détaché
oh
une pince parlante et passe
et là dedans c'est simplement un tube
peut-être un morceau de la moto je sais
pas ça veut pas dire seydoux
un autre voilà je me suis décalé mais
c'est vraiment pas pratique parce qu'à
peindre honte avec un regarder s'il ya
des choses parce que ça n'a pas empêché
les gens de voter j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya quelque chose déjà ou celle où
j'ai quelque chose et un morceau de
voiture ouais ça fait avoir cette
voiture et j'ai trouvé des cartes panini
aussi silva qui font la collection je
peux vous les donner elles sont un peu
dommage
elle était là au bord donc bon c'est bon
signe qui a une activité mais c'est
quelque chose là où ce héros ou ou ou
projet
quelque chose de gros haut ce que c'est
aulas tient aux deux moteurs breath away
ça c'est morceau de moteur
les pistons
son auteur le patient va changer quelque
chose
oui oh oui
boules de pétanque
ouais quelque chose de gros il lâche
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être
120 autres voitures à l'arrivée pas bon
je vous reprends quand je les jette en
pâtit ta thune party
qu'est ce que c'est que ça au regard des
roquettes et d'armes non c'est possible
non je crois une crosse d'armes
un truc de fou les gars ohlala oh là là
toi je n'aime pas te laisser tomber
si je dois y passer la nuit la peintre
est parce que ça c'est intéressant
c'est même très intéressant parce que si
c'est une crosse et une arme lourde
ou peut-être l'isi avec
tout casser d'auto cross repliable
n'être pas démontable en tout cas bon
bah j'ai vu ce que c'est et s'éveille
bien à mon sens bagnols
comment a fait plein pas le premier ni
le dernier sur ce spot
à
cette galère ces trucs et donc à deux ça
va mais seuls à ces galets plein d'eau
de van hoye [ __ ] il est quand même
beaucoup
il est beau parce que je l'étais like je
vais chercher mon frère macway holtz un
peu là c'est autre chose
avec en une semaine bon je commence à
être fatigué mais encore des choses donc
ce spot
il n'est pas terminée j'ai honte de voir
venir ce parce qu'un sacré spot
ils en ont vraiment mis partout j'ai
encore quelque chose de gros qui est
chez nous petit parasol ou parfois pu
t'en fous tu es ex a pourtant expliqué
bon voila en gros pour les trouvailles
du jour là j'ai refait un dernier
pistons on est à bahia de tous il ya eu
moins de goût d'un moto que prévu pour
aujourd'hui mais il y en avait quand
même suffisamment donc tout arranger
tout ça et c'est parti j'espère que
cette vidéo de pécharmant vous a plu ou
en tout cas elle m'a énormément plu on a
trouvé des trucs de folie comme
d'habitude l'objet le plus fou que j'ai
trouvé c'est ce qui semble être une
crosse de fusil mitrailleur ou peu
importe
en tout cas c'est une crosse d'armes de
guerre probablement au fusil je sais pas
à voir si vous savez dans les
commentaires en tout cas ce spot on va y
retourner que mon frère on va sortir le
morceau de portières et chercher
l'argent qui va avec ça
portez vous bien et à bientôt pour une
nouvelle vidéo